[Music]
we came up with a new program that I
think is gonna be a big hit it's a
reality show that was inspired by the
popularity of Shark Tank the show yeah
that show features inventors who are
trying to get backing for their projects
and we did a show sort of similar to
that here's a sneak peek today almost
800 million people don't have access to
clean drinking water but what if I said
I could make that statistic completely
disappear and I can do it for just
pennies introducing my invention a
portable globally adaptable instant
water purifier this is clearly brilliant
I'm asking for a $50,000 investment in
return for a 10% stake in my company
okay first of all I love the idea it's
good for the world and it's practical a
but before I invest my 50k I have to ask
one question about your product can I
can I get it's a water purifier and how
much would this product cost it's only
$29.99 follow-up question can I get why
hose there does that connect to the
genitals no why don't I just this money
frankly I have an easier time fifty
thousand dollars than that piece of junk
okay he's right your product
remind me what does it do again it saves
lives okay but it's probability factor
is big that's zero I'm going to have to
give it another goose egg in the area of
cannae fitness all I need is a
distribution channel so we can get more
in the hands of the poor get product for
ten years there are four active
prototypes in Amazon they're changing
lives every day here's how much I'm
willing to invest in your product oven
one of these out of our boardroom I
guess that guy hates money
next up which one of these inventors
will blow our judges away
you'll find out a cab
[Applause]